I mention that XFS uses log based
striping in software. So let's understand that technology
in a little bit more detail. You have clients on the local area network that
are writing to files. When a client makes a change to a file. The changes
that are made by this client to files are written to an append only log.
And this append only log is a data
structure. This log segment is a data structure
in the memory of the client in the
distributed file system and this append only data
structure contains ,the changes made to files on
this client node. And for instance, this could
be a change for a particular file X, this could be a change for another file
Z and so on, and so forth. And this is an append only data structure that is
residing at this client. Similarly, there is a log
segment that is available at this client. For the
changes made to files on this node, and when
this log segment fills up beyond a certain capacity,
you decide on a certain threshold, and once that
threshold number of fragments have been written in this
log segment, then you decide that it's time
now to write to the disk. So you take
these log fragments,and compute the parity, which is the
check sum or ECC, whatever you may want to call
it, and this becomes the log segment that I want to write to the disk.
And you take this and stripe it across storage servers. So you take
this,particular log fragment along with its ECC and
stripe it on storage servers so that it is
now available on the storage system and as I
mentioned, you want to do this periodically in order
to avoid the chance of [INAUDIBLE] Data loss due to
failures of a particular node, and that's what you're
doing every periodically. Same thing is happening on this
so if you look at the storage server, you
see that the storage server has the log segments that
have been written by this client, and the log segment
that has been written by the log segment that has
been written by this client. All of this, gets into
the storage servers, and the other thing that you want to
do is, you don't want every log segment to be
written on all the disks available on the local area
network, you don't want to do that. This again is
concerned with solving the small rate problem, and therefore, what we
want to do is subset the storage servers, and say if, let's say i have 100
storage servers available on the local area network.
I might decide that every log segment is
going to write its log over a small fraction of that maybe 10 servers. And this
client may similarly choose a subset of storage
servers to write it on. The subset of storage
servers that is used for striping a given log segment
is called a stripe group, for that particular log segment.